Consider the following set of events on node N1 and node N2. N1 is sending a
message and the act of sending the message,
the event associated with that is F. And
A is the act of receiving the same message on node N2. And B is another event on
node N1. Textually follows this send event. And G is another event on node N2.
Textually follows the receive event G. Now the
question for you, what can you say about the
relationship between the events A and B? What
can you say about the relationship between these two
events A and B? I'm going to give you
three choices. The first choice is A happened before
B, so I'm going to say that is the first
choice. The second choice I'm going to say is B
happened before A. And the third choice is neither.
And it's okay if you get it wrong, it's
just to, sort of, prime the pump for the
next concept that I'm going to describe to you.